[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono nato in un piccolo paesino ai piedi
delle
in provincia di Catania Diciamo che
appena nato fu già abbastanza sveglio
per accorgermi che nella mia famiglia
comandavano i grandi questa cosa non mi
piaceva E iniziai a ribellarmi iniziai
anche a buscarle di santa ragione mi
ricordo che le botte più forti me le
dava la mia povera nonna Probabilmente
della famiglia era quella che mi voleva
più bene come si usava a quel tempo noi
bambini io e i miei fratelli venivamo
sbattuti al mattino presto fuori di
casaa vivevamo nella viuzza e alla sera
rientravamo vi Confido che spesso non
trovavamo nulla da mangiare andavamo a
letto mangiando un po' di pane bagnato
nello zucchero con qualche insalata di
limone e la mia famiglia era molto ma
molto povera talmente povera che la mia
povera nonna mi portava con sé in piazza
del Mercato a fare la spesa e mi aveva
insegnato a rubare mentre lei parlava
con un commerciante io gli infilavo
qualcosa nella borsa della spesa solo
che una volta mi scoprirono e mia nonna
mi diede un sonoro schiaffone
gridandogli sei o sette nipoti quindi
cercava di tutto per arrangiarsi a 6
anni iniziai a andare a scuola fui
subito bocciato in prima elementare la
stessa cosa accade anche a seconda
elementare a 9 anni per la mia famiglia
Ero già abbastanza grande e mi mandarono
a lavorare in un cantiere edile a
trasportare sacchi di cemento da 50 kg
adesso questa cosa vi può fare il nor
ridire ma insomma a quel tempo nel
profondo sud il lavoro minorile era
molto sfruttato In seguito a causa della
separazione dei miei genitori igrai al
Nord igrai a Liguria dove fu rinchiuso
in collegio l'impatto col collegio fu
tremendo Mi
mancava la mia libertà la mia Tera
e mi mancava persino le botte che mi
dava la mia povera nonna mi mancava
tutto Mi trovai circondato da tutti
questi bambini che parlavano in italiano
si facevano il segno della croce prima
di mangiare io parlavo in dialetto mi
chiamavano terù Insomma mi sentivo
proprio emarginato l'unica difesa
l'unica arma che avevo era
l'aggressività e incominciai a essere
proprio
indisciplinato poi vi Confido che la
cosa che non riuscivo a capire perché
tutte le mattine dovevo andare in chiesa
stare in ginocchio davanti un signore
sconosciuto messo in croce io dentro di
me dicevo Ma io ho nulla da farmi
perdonare a parte forse la colpa di
essere nato perché perché nella mia
famiglia la religione non era praticata
Probabilmente perché non era roba da
mangiare
e un giorno però un giovane prete mi
raccontò una storia una storiella che
c'era un bambino che i Fratti è stato
abbandonato e i Fratti l'avevano
raccolto questo bambino parlava con con
Gesù andava è andato una volta in un
solaio e si è messa a parlare con Gesù
messo in croce e Gesù a risponderci
adesso quella storia mi colpì molto e
come tutti i bambini credi alle storie e
poi la storia fini male perché lui si
ammalò e Gesù lo prese in cielo con lui
questa
storiella mi colpì talmente che una sera
provai anch'io a andare in chiesa e mi
mise a parlare con Gesù ma niente da
fare lui a me non mi rispondeva Allora
mi viene la brillante idea Questa è la
storia di Marcellino Pane e Vino perché
portava il vino il pane a Gesù di di
portargli qualcosa anch'io da mangiare
Andai nella dispensa del collegio c'era
un grosso lucchetto
scassaioli
dolci della frutta e anche del vino ma
niente da fare lui non mi rispondeva
e gli confidai perché era un bambino
emarginato che nessuno mi voleva bene ma
niente da fare lui lui non muoveva
neppure un muscolo questa cosa mi mi
deluse Talmente che giorai me stesso che
da grande sarei diventato cattivo col
senno di poi credo di esserci riuscito
perché fui mandato via da quel collegio
girai altri collegi fin quando la mia
famiglia O meglio quello che rimaneva
dalla mia famiglia decise di prendermi
in casa una volta in casa trovai le
solite difficoltà economiche e Inai a
commettere piccoli reati e poi vedendo
il fac il guadagno Come si suol dire
incominciai ad alzare il tiro fin quando
era il
1972 fui arrestato durante una rapina in
un ufficio postale e Così fu portato in
carcere il carcere di Marassi a Genova
fui miso
fui sono messo nella sezione dei
Minorenni a quel tempo noi minorenni
sapevamo n primo piano e gli altri nei
piani degli adulti l'impatto con il
carcere minorile fu fu devastante fu
ancora peggio di quello del collegio poi
quelli erano gli anni delle rivolte mi
ritrovai mischiato in una di queste
rivolte fui duramente punito anche lì
fui legato al letto di contenzione loro
in gergo Lo chiamavano la Barilla fui
legato 15 giorni mani e piedi e E questa
esperienza mi molto giurai a me stesso
che quando sarei uscito mi sarei
vendicato e anche lì penso di esserci
riuscito perché uscì dal carcere molto
più incattivito di quando era entrato
poi in carcere nascono nei luoghi di
sofferenza nascono delle delle forti
amicizie che poi ti porti ti porti
dietro quando sei in libertà e poi in
seguito a causa di una guerra fra bande
rivali per pered dominio di attività
lecc nel territorio sono stato arrestato
nel 1991 e
condannato per vari reati e anche per
reati di mafia alla pena dell'er gastro
ostativo fin quando nel
1992 dopo le stragi Falcone e Borsellino
fui sottoposto a regime di tortura
Democratico dal 41
bis in Italia esistono due tipi di
ergastolo c'è cosiddetto ergastolo
normale che poi tanto normale quello non
lo è e poi c'era il Gasto l stativo che
tu non potrai mai uscire dal carcere se
in cella non ci metti un altro a posto
tuo Quindi ero sicuro che di me sarebbe
uscito solo il mio cadavere fui
sottoposto a questo
terribile regime e all'asinara poi un
giorno come appena accessoria mi colpì
l'isolamento di urno mi erano venuti a
prendere dalla sezione che condividevo
con altri compagni mi misero nella
sezione di isolamento mi misero in una
cella mi chiusero il cancello mi
chiusero e il blindato mi chiusero lo
spioncino e per un anno e 6 mesi non ho
potuto più parlare e vedere nessuna
persona me veniva la guardia apriva lo
spioncino mi dava da mangiare
e e stavo 24 ore su 24 solo a parlare un
pocoa mia ombra le condizioni
igienico-sanitarie di quel carcere erano
devastanti
Mancava l'acqua potabile dal bagno alla
turca entravano i Toppi io gli infilavo
una bottiglia di plastica ma loro con
quei dentini riuscivano a risicare la
plastica e entrarmi dentro non avevo
proprio nulla per cui neppure i libri da
poter leggere perché in quel carcere i
libri non entravano CAD in depressione
chi è quella ergastolano che non pensa
di uscire dal carcere togliendosi la
vita io ci pensavo un po' tutti i giorni
e un po' tutte le notti però la mia
compagna nelle numerose lettere che mi
scriveva mi diceva Devi vivere devi
vivere devi vivere rimane un punto di
riferimento affettivo per i tuoi figli
Quindi a un certo punto mi trovai due
condanne una condanna all pena
dell'ergastolo e una una condanna che
per amore Dovevo continuare a vivere che
è ancora più terribile di quella della
condanna dell'ergastolo un giorno per
fortuna un insegnante in pensione
cosiddetto amico di penna Mi propose
sono quegli quelle persone che scrivono
a detenuti senza conoscerli Mi propose
di di di iniziare a studiare gli risposi
ma eh Come faccio a studiare se non mi
entrano i
libri lui a sua volta mi disse Beh
incominciamo a trovare scuse Se vuoi
studiare Ti strappo pagine di libri e te
ne mando per lettera Ecco io ho iniziato
a studiare con queste modalità però eh
avevo la censura spesso queste lettere
venivano bloccate perché pensavano che
erano dei Pezzini mafiosi quindi nello
studiare trovavo delle difficoltà ho
trovato delle difficoltà enormi Però
come a volte queste difficoltà mi
aiutavano a fare mattina e a fare
sera nel senso che
adesso avevo dei problemi da risolvere e
capire perché la mtip cazo dei numeri
negativi con quelli positivi diventano
positivi Insomma studiare da solo senza
sostegno senza libri è una delle cose
più difficili che mi sia capitato però
queste difficoltà mi hanno aiutato a
uscire insomma a uscir da dalla
depressione Poi per
fortuna mi viene tolto regime di tortura
del 41 bis vengo messo in alta sicurezza
e Dove almeno potevo avere i libri ho ho
continuato a studiare mi sono diplomato
mi sono laurato in scienze giuridiche in
pudenza e mi sono laureato anche in
filosofia Adesso vi ho citato i miei
titoli accademici non certo per darmi
delle arie perché ho capito anche che
non c'è cosa peggiore di un ignorante
che studia Ecco non è lo studio ti dà
gli strumenti ma non è detto che ti
fanno diventare una brava
persona ho vissuto per 25 anni con
l'ergastolo stativo ripeto sicuro che di
me sarebbe uscito solo il mio cadavere
per fortuna questo non è accaduto sono
un'eccezione a tutti gli effetti penso
di essere l'unico ergastolano di essere
di essere uscito da questa
ostruttivi Diciamo che sono un
fallimento per il sistema Penitenziario
italiano perché con me ha fallito non è
riuscito non dico a migliorarmi ma dico
non è riuscito a peggiori perché i dati
sono chiari Il 70% che entra in carcere
ci ritorna vuol dire che in Italia il
carcere non è la medicina Ma diciamo che
è piuttosto la malattia qualcuno di voi
può dire Beh funziona per col 30% che
non rientra più in carcere allora Vi
pongo la domanda ma non entra più in
carcere perché è migliorata perché è
cambiata o perché ha paura del carcere
Ecco rispondetemi da soli uno non deve
fare ATI non perché ha paura del carcere
Ma perché è sbagliato eh fare dei reati
Ecco questa diciamo è la mia è la mia
esperienza di vita ovviamente
e per ben 27 anni di carcere Io sono un
esperto di trovarmi altrove Io diciamo
ci sono stato poco con la mente con il
cuore in carcere perché mi sono
inventato un mondo immaginario ho sempre
immaginato di trovarmi accanto ai miei
figli ho sempre immaginato di parlare
con loro Insomma sono un esperto di
trovarmi altrove
eh nel voglio raccontarvi la domanda che
mi ha fatto il presidente del tribunale
di sorveglianza di di Venezia quando mi
ha tolto il carcere ostativo mi ha detto
Beh anche in modo un po' ironico Beh
musum C Ho preso una laurea le Ne ha
prese tre quindi il carcere gli ha fatto
bene Ecco io gli risposi No guardi il
carcere non è una clinica per g miliard
soprattutto in Italia se voi sapete i
dati delle persone che si tolgono la
vita in carcere Ecco L'anno scorso mi
sembra che sono sta 64 persone che si
sono tolte la vita in carcere chi si
toglie la vita in carcere non è che non
l'ama anzi che quelli che si tolgono la
vita in carcere l' amano così tanto che
non la vogliono vedere appassire nelle
mura di un
carcere ovviamente è stato importante la
mia mia famiglia i miei figli e la mia
compagna che non mi hanno mai
abbandonato son è stato importante lo
studio che mi ha dato gli strumenti ma
la cosa più importante sono state le
relazioni sociali e e anche la mia la
mia forza nell' immaginarmi un
mondo immaginario cioè sempre di di
cercare l'altrove Perché poi questa è la
cosa più importante per superare in
momenti difficili
e gli ho detto sono state le relazioni
sociali che questa è la verità
l'incontro con il bene e Cito sempre una
persona disabile una volontaria della
comunità Papa Giovanni X che mi veniva a
trovare nel carcere di spoletto e io un
giorno mi domandai Ma come mai questa
persona con tutte le difficoltà che ha
mi viene trovare in carcere Come mai a
un certo punto questa persona Incomincia
a farmi paura perché mi voleva far
diventare buono e io gli risposi Guarda
non venirmi più a trovare io non posso
diventare buono Io qui in carcere ci
devo morire Io ho bisogno di continuare
a essere cattivo perché il carcere
Purtroppo è il luogo più legale di
qualsiasi altro posto però poi il bene
diciamo è contagioso una volta che tu lo
scopri incomincia a scavarti dentro a
levarti tutti gli alibi che chi fa del
male si giustifica da
solo e quindi diciamo sono stati le
relazioni l'incontro con la figlia di
Aldo Moro Margherita
h e poi ovviamente è una volta iniziate
queste relazioni mi sono dedicato alla
scrittura
e il problema poi e quando esci dal
carcere Specialmente dopo una lunga pena
come la mia inizia un altro tipo di pena
ti devi riabituare a vivere perché il
carcere ti
disabituarsi mi compra un paio di
pantaloni mi dice papà vatteli a
misurare Vado nello stanzino tiro la
tenda e vedo che c'era dentro uno una
persona un po' vecchia con pochi capelli
un po' grassa chiudo la tenda e gli dico
a mia figlia guarda c'è uno dentro dopo
un po' mia figlia mi fa Ma sei sicuro
che c'è uno dentro E certo l'ho visto
tira la tenda e non c'era nessuno Cos'è
che avevo visto io avevo visto la mia
immagine nello specchio perché e Fra Fra
le tante cose io per 27 anni e non
potuto mai vedere il mio fisico n uno
specchio non ho visto il mio fisico
invecchiare perché in carcere hai solo
un piccolo specchietto da poterti
fare la barba ecco per diri che anche
quando esci dal carcere dopo una lunga
pena inizia un altro tipo da pena Quindi
io sono ancora alla ricerca del di
essere altrove perché
Perché ti
disabituare alla felicità e anche quando
sei felice pensi di più a quanto sei
stato felice per più di di un quarto di
secolo che altro posso aggiungere nel
tempo stringe e io preferisco fermarmi
qua
e mandarvi un sorriso uno da parte mia e
una parte del mio cuore e vi auguro a
tutti voi di cercare l'altrove e di non
trovarlo mai perché la La vera bellezza
è quello di cercare
[Applauso]
Grazie
n